since the original the fast and the
furious in 2001
each film in the franchise has added
more names onto the roster
with two decades worth of fast films and
more on the way that's
a lot of faces and backstories to
remember so
we've recapped every main character
story including where they started
where they are now and any notable stops
they've made along the way
when we meet dominic tireto in the fast
and furious he's helping his sister mia
run their family's small la market
while also running an operation stealing
electronics off
moving 18 wheelers and participating in
illegal street races
dom was once incarcerated for assaulting
the man he blamed for causing the
accident that killed his
father however that wasn't enough to
steer him away from crime which
eventually led to him going on the run
to avoid arrest
dom's been with his girlfriend letty
since they were teenagers
they eventually marry in the fourth film
although their wedding isn't revealed
until the seventh
in between when dom's forced to flee
justice again
he learns letty's been killed after
taking time to grieve he dates elena
nevis
fathering a child with her although he
doesn't learn about his son's existence
until
months after he's born while elaine is
pregnant he learns let he's alive but
suffering from amnesia elena steps aside
so they can be together eventually letty
regains her memories and
following elena's death letty and dom
raised her son together whom dom
names after his best friend everyone
meet brian after many films spent
evading justice
dom's taste for crime increases over the
course of the series although he tends
to target greedy corporations and
corrupt crime lords
but the most valuable thing to him is
family
specifically the crew he's assembled to
help him pull off his various schemes
the most important thing in life will
always be the people in this room
right here
right now in fast and furious 6 dom and
his crew partner with the government to
bring down various terrorists earning
them
full pardons for their past crimes
introduced in the vast and the furious
undercover lapd officer brian o'connor
initially ingratiates himself with dom
under false pretenses his goal is to
earn dom's trust so that he can catch
him
and his crew in the act and arrest them
all but gradually his friendship with
dom
turns genuine and brian ultimately
chooses dom over his career
brian goes underground but is found by
the fbi who offer him a deal
bring down drug lord carter verone and
get pardoned
brian agrees and joins the fbi later he
sends letty undercover with cartel
leader arturo braga but
later learns she's been killed to track
down her killer he reunites with dom
as well as dom's sister mia whom brian
briefly dated years before
when dom kills leddy's supposed murderer
and earns himself a lifelong prison
sentence
brian ditches his career again to
partner with mia and free him
later when nia tells brian she's
pregnant brian and don decide to pull
off
one last heist that will allow them to
drop off the grid
and live in peace but brian is pulled
back to crime twice
more after that once when dom learns
that letty's alive
and again when their crew is targeted by
a terrorist
finally with a second baby on the way
brian decides to step away from the fast
furious lifestyle for good settling down
with mia and his growing family
off-screen brian was written out of the
franchise because of paul walker's
sudden death during production of
furious seven
while mia can still return as part of
the crew brian's story is complete
with his character last seen driving off
happily into the sunset
gledy ortiz has long been dom's partner
in
everything sticking by him even when dom
keeps leaving her behind
after he goes on the run at the end of
the fast and the furious letty spends
several years tracking him down
eventually finding him in the dominican
republic
picking up where they left off the
couple wastes no time in secretly
marrying before
pulling their biggest heist yet but when
the plan goes sideways dom goes on the
run once again
leaving lety on her own letty brokers a
deal with brian
she'll go undercover to help bring down
braga in exchange for dom's pardon
but when she uncovers a plot to kill her
she tries to flee only to be left for
dead
eventually leddy awakens in the hospital
with amnesia and is taken in by criminal
owen shaw
letty works for years as part of shaw's
crew with no memory of her former life
but switches sides when she encounters
dom
and he wins her trust the two date for a
while but letty breaks up with him
because she doesn't think they should be
together while she still lacks her
memories
however she regains them when dom's
nearly killed and the two
finally take their long overdue
honeymoon even when dom appears to
betray the team after being blackmailed
letty never loses faith and welcomes him
back into the family with open arms
and you know i never will
i know mia toretto resisted her
brother's criminal endeavors for a long
time but she's eventually pulled in when
dom is sentenced to prison and she helps
brian break him out
after that mia sticks with brian as they
travel internationally and pull off
daring heists
when they're double-crossed by a crime
lord named reyes brian and dom believe
they'll need to split up to avoid being
caught
mia disagrees revealing she's pregnant
the trio instead
decide to recruit a crew to steal 100
million dollars of reyes's money so that
they can go underground and live in
peace
once the heist is complete mia and brian
settle down in the canary islands
there she gives birth to their son jack
afterwards she agrees that brian should
help dom
find letty while she stays with jack but
she gets kidnapped by owen shaw
after being freed just as mia realizes
she's expecting their second child
their house blows up brian joins dom for
one
final mission and once their family is
finally safe again
mia and brian retire for good however
mia will be rejoining the action
this time without brian when her
estranged older brother jacob shows up
in f9 roman pierce started stealing cars
at a young age but when his friend brian
o'connor joined the lapd
roman grew resentful especially when
brian did
nothing to help when roman was arrested
the two reconnect in too fast too
furious when brian recruits roman to
help in an investigation requiring them
to go undercover
in return the fbi promises them both a
pardon
they complete their mission and clear
their names and recover a large amount
of stolen money
unbeknownst to the fbi though roman also
sets aside a generous portion of the
cash for himself
roman re-enters the picture in fast 5
when brian and dom need someone on the
team who can talk his way out of
any situation after pocketing 11 million
dollars from that heist
roman lives lavishly buying expensive
cars and a private jet but still rejoins
the crew whenever he's needed
he helps dom find letty and foil both
shaw brothers
and sticks around after brian retires
when dom seems to betray the crew while
being blackmailed by cipher
roman is part of the group that works to
stop him and is quick to welcome him
back
once the truth is revealed introduced in
too fast too furious
super mechanic tej meets brian o'connor
while brian is living in miami
and the two become friends through the
street racing scene later tash assists
brian and roman in their undercover fbi
assignment
brian brings tej back in for the heist
and fast five
using his tech skills to hack into
reyes's advanced security system
tesh also becomes close to roman
although the two never miss an
opportunity to get under each other's
skin
from fast five on tej works as an
integral part of the crew
working as the team's mechanic hacker
and occasional driver
only appearing in too fast too furious
tsugi is a street racer with a mostly
female crew of her own
she is friends with brian and tej and
proves a valuable asset when roman and
brian need help throwing the police off
their scent
while tez drives brian's car suki drives
romans
leading the police on a wild goose chase
away from their actual targets
a significant character in too fast too
furious monica fuentes is an undercover
us customs agent who's working to expose
miami
drug lord carter varone when brian and
roman are also embedded in the operation
monica blows her cover to pass brian
important information
realizing monica's betrayal varone takes
her hostage aboard his boat but brian
and roman distract him long enough for
monica
to take advantage of the situation she
holds her own at gunpoint until she's
able to arrest him
several years later she alerts hobbs
that letty is still alive
ex-mossad agent giselle is introduced as
an employee of arturo braga in the
fourth film
however giselle warns dom that braga
plots to kill his drivers
later dom saves gisele's life then
recruits gisele in fast five as an
official member of his crew
i think i'm in love after becoming a
couple in
fast five gisele and han are in hong
kong together when they receive dom's
call to come help stop
shaw and save letty in the sixth film
tragically toward the end of the film
she sells hanging off the top of the
speeding car when she sees one of shaw's
henchmen preparing to
kill han making a split-second call
giselle releases her grip on han's hand
in order to kill his attacker
saving his life as she falls to her
death han got his start in director
justin lin's earlier film better luck
tomorrow
in high school han was part of an
organized cheating operation that spun
out of control and eventually resulted
in a murder following the events of that
film han left to travel the world he met
dom in mexico and occasionally helped
with various missions
han's first appearance is in the third
film but chronologically his first
mission is in the fourth
released film in the franchise which
serves as a prequel to the third
quiet observant and adaptable han helps
with dom's heists in the fourth
fifth and sixth movies during which he
also falls in love with fellow crew
members zelf
the two dream of globetrotting and
growing old together but
those plans are dashed when giselle
sacrifices herself to save han while
working to take down owen shaw
grieving han heads to tokyo where he
befriends a group of local street racers
and takes american teen sean boswell
under his wing
han also begins stealing from the yakuza
eventually finding himself in a
high-speed chase once his crimes are
discovered
the chase ends in a horrific crash but
it turns out to be no accident
han was targeted by owen's brother
deckard shaw it appears han dies in the
crash
but f9 reveals that somehow han
actually survived and will rejoin dom's
crew
the youngest protagonist in the
franchise sean boswell appears in the
fast and the furious tokyo drift as an
alabama teen with a penchant for
reckless driving
after being sent to tokyo to live with
his father sean quickly falls in with
the city street racing scene but the
japanese racers all know how to
drift maneuvering around tight corners
via controlled skids
a skill which shawn is initially unable
to master
han takes shawn under his wing and
teaches him how to drift
sean also flirts with a girl that turns
out to be the girlfriend of takashi
the local drift king and the nephew of a
yakuza member after hans apparently
killed while being pursued by the yakuza
shawn challenges takashi to a race with
the loser agreeing to leave tokyo for
good
thanks to han's teaching sean beats
takashi and is crowned the new drift
king
afterward he meets dom while dom is in
tokyo investigating han's death
an american army bratz twinkie
eventually landed in tokyo
selling stolen goods out of han's garage
he met sean boswell in high school and
they become friends after they bond over
twinkie's unique
car through twinkie sean is introduced
to han and the tokyo street racing crowd
and when shawn finds himself on the
wrong side of the yakuza after han's
death twinkie even gives him money to
pay off his debts
the two remain friends at the end of the
movie with twinkie serving as the second
in command to the new drift gang
originally serving as a secondary
antagonist in fast five luke hobbs
enters the picture as a diplomatic
security service agent
tasked with tracking down the crew
however after finally getting the upper
hand
and arresting dom brian and several
members of their crew
hobbs caravan is ambushed when dom brian
and their friend vince save hobbs life
he decides to join them
to get revenge after the mission is
complete hobbes returns to the dss where
he learns letty ortiz is alive
hobbs passes this intel to don and after
dom's crew assists in tracking letty
down and capturing owen shaw
hobbs is able to negotiate pardons for
everyone hobbes is later injured when
deckard shaw breaks into the dss in
search of information on the crew but
still helps bring shaw to justice
later when hobbs is tasked with an off
the books mission
he calls on dom and his crew to help him
but dom's double cross for cypher winds
up sending hobbs to prison
he breaks out and helps the team stop
cipher later hobbes is tasked by the cia
with teaming up with deckard shaw to
recover a dangerous bioweapon which
leads to him reconnecting with his
estranged family in samoa
we meet elena in fast five when she's
recruited by hobbs to assist in his
investigation
but when she comes face to face with dom
she opts not to shoot him when she has
the chance
in turn dumb saves her from reyes men
making elena question whether he could
really be guilty of the crimes he's
accused of
after dom and brian saved her life again
elena leaves her law enforcement career
to go on the run with dom
the two begin a relationship on the
canary islands where she also grows
close to brian and mia
but when dom learns letty's alive elena
urges him to find her
elena stays behind to protect mia and
baby jack
getting jack to safety when mia is
kidnapped after dom
finds letty elena steps aside not
revealing she's pregnant with dom's
child
eventually after joining the dss with
hobbs elena gives
birth in secret shortly after she and
her infant son are kidnapped by cipher
to use as leverage against dumb
elena tells dom she's given the baby a
middle name marcos
but she wanted dom to choose his first
name elena is soon executed by cipher as
punishment for dom's insubordination
we meet vince in the fast and the
furious as a loyal member of dom's crew
who
instantly distrusts brian part of
vince's issue with brian is mia's
attraction to him since vince wants her
attention for himself
when the cruise heist goes drastically
wrong at the end of the first film
vince is seriously injured prompting
brian to blow his cover to get vince
medical attention
at some point after his recovery vince
goes on the run winding up in rio de
janeiro where he meets the woman who'd
eventually become his wife and mother of
his son
after spending years resenting brian
vince ultimately forgives him when he
returns in past five
he offers shelter to brian and mia and
rejoins the crew
tragically he's killed by reyes as a man
when they attack hops
so dom gives vince's portion of the 100
million dollar heist to vince's wife and
son
owen shaw turned mercenary after being
dishonorably discharged from the
military he became an associate of
arturo braga which is how he met lady
ortiz intending to finish her off after
braga's initial attempt to kill her
failed
but instead he recruited letty as part
of his criminal crew
after braga's arrest shaw begins
stealing components to build an advanced
weapon of mass destruction
which he intends to sell off to the
highest bidder he acts
ruthlessly willingly sacrificing members
of his crew and kidnapping mia to use
his leverage to secure his freedom
he's ultimately stopped by dom and is
grievously injured in the process
after being hospitalized for an extended
period of time
owen is transferred to a secret location
while being blackmailed by cipher dom
makes a deal with shaw's mother to find
him in exchange for her family's
assistance to which she agrees
owen then is instrumental in helping
rescue dom's baby from cipher
introduced in fast and furious 6 as a
dss agent and associate of blue cubs
riley hicks is an ex-soldier with an
impressive record she works alongside
hobbs to track down owen shaw and his
team and
is helpful in both combat and extracting
information from informants
however after dom's group helps hobbs
arrest shah
riley reveals she's been a double agent
the whole time and is romantically
involved with shaw from that point on
riley is openly a part of shaw's crew
and proves willing to kill for him in
cold blood riley is ultimately killed by
letty when let he shoots her with a
harpoon gun
causing her to fall from shaw's plane to
her death
although brian and dom spent most of
fast and furious working for the drug
lord known as braga it turns out the man
they thought was braga was actually a
decoy the real braga was the second in
command who'd gone by the name roman
campos
those closest to him knew about the
deception but everyone else
bought into the lie helping the real
cartel leader avoid detection
for a while this helps him fly under
brian and dom's radar however they're
eventually able to apprehend him in
mexico and he's sentenced to life in
prison
at some point prior to this though he's
formed an alliance with owen shaw who
helped influence braga's operation
and whom braga hired to kill letty while
braga is in prison
brian poses as a prisoner to get close
to him in order to find out more
information about what happened to letty
braga tells him
everything before attempting to kill him
but brian manages to get the upper hand
stabbing braga in the leg in the process
leo and santos are friends of doms from
his time in the dominican republic
the pair are instrumental in helping dom
plan and
execute the fuel heist at the beginning
of the fourth film and
reappear at the end of the film to help
brian and mia break dom out of prison
after receiving their cut of their
multi-million dollar score at the end of
fast five
santos and leo head to a casino where
they wager all their money
playing roulette we never learn who wins
or loses but they show up again later in
the fate of the furious as part of dom's
plan to fake deckard's death proving
they still have dom's trust
introduced in the fourth film fbi agent
michael stosiak
initially gets along with brian but the
two butt heads when stosiak brings mia
in for questioning
after brian tricks him into letting her
go stosiak is suspicious of brian's
loyalties
he winds up second guessing him at a
critical juncture that puts their
undercover operation at risk however
stasiak still has a good enough
impression of brian to help him sneak
back into the u.s
in fast and furious six he then gives
brian an
alias and embeds him in the prison where
braga's being kept so brian can question
him
first introduced in furious 7 ramsay is
an accomplished hacker who catches the
crew's attention after she invents a
device
called the god's eye which can be used
to track down anyone on the planet
realizing how dangerous the god's eye
can be ramsay sends it to a friend to
keep
safe but she's then kidnapped by a
mercenary seeking the device
knowing deckard shaw has targeted dom's
crew the government strikes a bargain
if dom retrieves ramsay and the god's
eye he can use it to track down shaw
after the crew rescues ramsay she helps
them track down the god's eye and
defeat shaw she eventually joins dom's
crew permanently
owen's brother deckard first appears at
the end of fast and furious 6 tracking
down
and presumably killing han in tokyo a
former clandestine military operative
and mi6 agent turned mercenary deckard
uses his skills to break into the dss
offices
and steal information on dom's team
while he's in tokyo
he also mails a bomb to dom's childhood
home where mia and brian are living
and detonates it while on the phone with
dom deckard continues his attempts to
hunt and kill the crew but he's
ultimately thwarted by dom
and taken into cia custody hobbes is
later put into the cell
opposite him and the two waste no time
in annoying each other
but before long the pair escaped during
a prison riot initiated by mr nobody
a covert government agent reluctantly
deckard agrees to work with dom's crew
to stop cipher since he also blames her
for owen's fate
after helping them track down dom and
seiper it appears deckard is killed by
dom but that's revealed to be a ruse
facilitated by his mother
with owen deckard breaks into cipher's
plane and rescues dom's son
whom he returns safely to don later
deckard's recruited by the cia to assist
hogs to their mutual irritation
in recovering a bioweapon possessed by
deckard's sister hattie
although cipher isn't introduced until
the fate of the furious
she's been pulling strings behind the
scenes for quite some time
she's hired owen shaw to steal the
components he was assembling in fast and
furious 6
and was the mastermind behind the plan
to steal the god's eye in furious 7.
it's even implied she has ties to braga
in the eighth movie cypher kidnaps elena
and her son to use his leverage to
manipulate dom which
works for a while however while cipher
knows that dom's loyalty lies with his
family she underestimates how far he'll
go to keep them safe
enabling him to eventually break free of
her control
motivated by power cipher's goal is to
start a nuclear war
even though her plans are thwarted by
the end of the eighth movie she manages
to escape and will be returning to
collect her revenge in
f9 no one knows mr nobody's real name
or even which government organization he
works for all we know is that he's a
covert agent who shows up in furious 7
offering dom the chance to track down
deckard shaw in exchange for his
assistance
describing himself as a shadow mr nobody
has
abundant resources and technology at his
disposal
and is untethered by official policies
and procedures
mr nobody shows up again in the fate of
the furious staging a prison riot to
free hobbs and shaw so that they can
help dom's crew track down their leader
meanwhile little nobody shows up as mr
nobody's protege
in the fate of furious so then who is he
him he's nothing he's like less than me
while not on the level of most of dom's
crew little nobody still participates in
the high-speed effort to stop cypher
from launching a nuclear submarine
we first met shaw family matriarch
magdalene in the fate of the furious
when dom sneaks away from cipher long
enough to ask her for help
dom offers queenie a deal in exchange
for her help rescuing his infant son
he will give her the location of her
incarcerated son
owen the trade is acceptable to magdalen
who
like dom values family above all else
sometime later queenie goes to prison
although we never learn why
but at the end of hobson shaw it's
implied that she's getting ready to
break herself
out thanks to a nail file hidden in a
cake delivered to her by deckard and
hattie
we don't know much about jacob who'll
debut in f9
but what we do know indicates he'll be
very different from the other toretto
siblings
dom and mia have never mentioned jacob
and maybe there's a good reason for that
the ninth fast and the furious film will
see jacob teaming with cypher to take
down his big brother which may prove to
be the biggest
challenge dom has ever faced jacob is a
skilled assassin
and of course an excellent precision
driver we'll learn what happened to set
the toretto siblings at one another's
throats when f9
finally speeds into theaters check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the fast
and the furious are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one